What's worse?
I'm all turned around.
Don't look at the street maps.
Stop.
This has gone too far.
It has to stop.
Where is he?
Please help.
We're going to help him.
Slow down.
We'll get through this.
I know.
Welcome back, everyone.
It's Charlie.
This will be my last of us. Episode
four Trailer Video.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references. We'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel.
I'm doing videos for all the episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get them.
We're also doing a giveaway
for HBO Max subscriptions
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and post all your theories on the trailer
on the comments.
Careful. Postponed for everything.
This happened on the last of us so far.
If you haven't
caught up with the episodes,
but at the end of episode three,
join Ellie arrived at Bill
and Frank's in Lincoln
just outside of Boston a little while
after they killed themselves,
finding Bill's letter to Joel,
giving him all his supplies, his car
that they desperately needed to get them
the rest of the way to Wyoming.
The episode in general was a big departure
from the video game story
because it is so much a Bill
and Frank's backstory.
You didn't really get that in the games,
but the end result of the episode
was pretty much the same.
But in the game, Bill really only
gave them the car itself and that was it.
In the episode,
they got a ton of supplies,
including Ellie's T-shirt from the games.
Most of everyone's
costumes, though, and all the props
are based on versions of the game,
but they are changing where
some of the items actually came from it.
If it wasn't clear in the episode, Bill's
car is meant to be the exact same
version of his car in the video game,
like it looks exactly the same.
But here's the next big change.
So in episode four,
there's a huge change in the video games
for that next
part of the story in the game.
The next major encounter happens
in Pittsburgh, Philadelphia,
but the showrunner and Neil Druckman
made it sound like this next major fight
that they have in this trailer
you see all these scenes in the city
is actually Kansas City, and it's
against the hunters, who are a group
from Pittsburgh in the games.
It seems like they just wanted them
to move across
the United States a little bit more,
like they wanted the city itself
to feel much different.
And Pittsburgh
is relatively close to Boston.
So on the show,
they will have gone way further
by the time that the encounter the hunters
what are the other big changes
is they've added a brand new character
that was in the games played by Melanie
Lynskey here, who's named Kathleen.
She's
meant to be the leader of the Hunters.
Now, like I said, the hunters
themselves are a huge group in the Games.
It is possible that they drive
past Pittsburgh in remark on it
like this, some sort of reference
to that part of the video game.
But a lot of what happens in the trailer
is part of their encounter
with the hunters
in Pittsburgh in the game.
So they are doing video game stuff.
They're just changing the location
In a few of the characters.
The hunters are an antagonist.
The group ruling over Pittsburgh
in the game after they overthrew Fedora,
the governmental force,
they're on the show.
It's going to be Kansas City, like I said,
and they are a huge group.
They're meant to be like
an opposing faction to the Fireflies,
Making the Walking Dead comparison again,
because we're talking about characters
that are kind of like zombies,
but they're being controlled by fungus.
And the last of us,
the hunters would be kind of like Negan's
group of saviors
compared to Rick's group of the survivors.
The hunters are meant to be way more
antagonistic, but they're a huge group.
Like,
Imagine if Negan swooped in The Walking
Dead, started covering way more cities.
The hunters, when they encounter them,
are meant to control this entire city.
But later you find their group
has continued
to spread across the United States.
So they get bigger and bigger
and more powerful.
At the beginning of the trailer,
they're camping in the woods overnight.
Ellie gets disgusted by the coffee,
is another reference to her,
remarking that she's never been
in the woods, been camping,
or even been in a car for that matter.
So everything they're doing on this
mission is just totally new to her.
And she's worried about the fungus
in general.
Like she's not totally fearless.
There's this sense of existential dread
hanging over everybody
living in the apocalypse just in general,
but just compare to Jill
in all of their scenes.
You can tell she's having
way more fun at all
this than he is to him,
it's still more of an obligation
that he's fulfilling a promise
that he made to test to complete the job.
So he's mostly doing this for Tess,
not so much for Ellie.
Get her the rest of the way,
at least at this point in their story.
He's not really doing it because he cares
about Ellie or anything like that.
He's only protecting her
because he promised Tess
to get her to the other fireflies alive.
But Joel does have that funny moment
briefly with her.
When she's complaining
about the coffee in the car, talking
about how it smells and looks terrible,
slurping loudly just to mess with her
a little, showing you that he does
actually have a sense of humor.
It is still so early
in the series in their story
that will slowly start to come out
more by the finale as they continue
to drive across the landscape.
We get wider shots of the Midwest.
They pass across the country
just showing you how nature slowly started
to take back the earth,
even though it's only been about 20 years.
The reason why you don't see
giant roving bands of infected,
unlike the Walking Dead with the Walkers,
is that the infected aren't guaranteed
to just keep on living indefinitely.
As Joel and Test said
previously in Episodes, a lot of them die
relatively soon for various reasons
before they can evolve into higher states.
But the general rule of thumb
is that the infected
will evolve into higher states
as long as they continue to live
the most dangerous one from the game
so far is the Rat King.
Like you
probably seen jokes about the Rat King,
even if you haven't played the games,
which is what they call the infected,
who's lived for over 20 years
and becomes its hybrid amalgamation
of a bunch of different types of infected
like a super fungus warrior
within the context of the last of US,
the Fireflies consider it
something of an anomaly
like nobody truly understands
Exactly how the fungus works
at that stage of development.
But the idea is that the Rat King
has this whole bunch of extra weapons
and armor growing around its body
because it's continued to evolve so much
and because it's meant to be the fusion
of a couple different types of infected
that'll kind of bond and grow together.
It's way, way bigger.
Maybe.
Maybe we'll see a Rat King
in like season two or season three.
Then in the trailer, Ellie gets them lost.
They start yelling at each other
because she's never been outside
the quarantine zone.
She's never tried to read a map like this.
Naturally, she's not going to be
a dynamite navigator on her first try.
They get lost in Kansas City,
like in the actual city.
They slam on the brakes to avoid hitting
someone, calling for help.
And this is a scene
taken directly from the games.
But it's happening in Pittsburgh,
in the games.
And it's part of the way the hunters
lay traps for unsuspecting guests,
luring people
who they refer to as tourists,
like people who aren't part of their group
already into a false sense of security,
helping the helpless
and preying on their good will.
But Joel correctly, smartly tells Ellie
they're not going to help him,
which is super smart on his part.
It's not him being an asshole.
It's just that paranoia, like the joke
that they reference in episode
three where
he's talking to Bill in the flashbacks.
Oh, I'm just like you.
We're extra careful in situations
like this, but here in this moment,
the wheels are turning in
Joel's head and he's thinking,
This is the way that I would play it
if I were trying to trap people in.
That's why they try to bail on it.
The Hunters group generally kills anybody
they can find, like shoot first,
ask questions later, even on their truck.
Here it says run in spray
paint on the front, kind of mocking
the people that they mow down with it.
Basically, anybody that travels
into their city, Kansas City, in this case
in the TV show, the hunters will kill
and they just try to take all their stuff.
And Joel and Ellie rolled in
with a truck full of supplies
in a big part of Joel and Ellie's story
during the next part, during episode
four, Episode five and beyond,
is them bonding
more as a pair while they're busy trying
to escape the hunters across the city?
Like they're literally fighting their way
across the city.
And they also use those moments for Joel
to start
answering more of Ellie's questions
that she keeps badgering him with.
They kind of had some of that energy
in episode three,
couple of scenes
where they're walking down the road,
and she kept asking him about his history,
just being really inquisitive.
There are way more moments like that
in episode four.
The only difference
is that in the last episode
he was still very reluctant,
didn't fully answer.
A lot of the questions are answered
very quickly
or was vague about some of his answers.
In episode four, he starts to open up
to her more in the sheer trauma
of what they go through trying to escape
the hunters in all their heartfelt chats
as they're running from all the bullets,
brings them much closer together.
Ultimately, the scene of Joel
getting stuck in the traffic jam
on the highway is earlier in the episode
before they make it into the city.
And it's the whole reason
why they have to go into the city
instead of just using the highway.
Because back in 2003,
when things went crazy with the fungus,
everyone started turning.
You had all these people
driving around at the time,
which led to a bunch of pileups
on the highway,
making portions of the highway system
unusable.
In present day.
We get the scene of Melanie
Lynskey is Kathleen, leader
of the Hunters holding someone captive,
another new character.
When he says this has to stop,
it's gone too far.
And she asks him where they are.
I'm assuming she's talking
about Joel and Ellie,
and it's happening later in the episode.
There's a couple fight scenes of them
running
through the buildings,
escaping the hunters, trying to kill them.
And I believe the next two episodes
will be here around this location
in Kansas City, around the Hunters
Episode four in episode five,
because there are a couple
of big characters in the game
that we've seen in the trailers
they encounter
in this same larger encounter
against the hunters.
So they've confirmed that they're going
to be characters on the show.
I'm assuming that happens relatively
soon after the events
of this particular episode.
Like it'll be the next episode after this.
No spoilers
from what's going on with their story.
We'll just wait till they drop the Episode
five trailer to talk about them.
I don't know if Melanie Lynskey
is supposed to be in multiple episodes
because she has a brand new character
that wasn't in the games
and in the games after they make it
through the Hunters portion of the story,
at least in the first game,
you only hear about the hunters briefly,
but they are still a huge antagonistic
faction looming in the background.
In a big rival to the Fireflies,
the group continues to get bigger
and spread through other cities
in the United States, getting larger,
controlling more territory.
In in the second game Last of US,
do they encounter another separate group
of hunters? Eventually.
So because they just confirmed
season two is going to be adapting
The Last of US
to our part of Last of US two,
they're going to break the second game
into a couple of different seasons.
I wouldn't be surprised
if they keep Melanie Lynskey as character
around longer term in future seasons,
but we'll see.
They've already been changing
a lot of stuff from the game,
so we'll see how they continue
to change stuff on the show.
But there are so many huge actors
that show up on this show.
We've only had three episodes,
but they're like a couple
really big actors
that only came for a couple of episodes.
There is some other footage
from previous trailers with Ella
using Bill's gun
while they're running through the streets.
I'm assuming this is from episode
four two in.
They're still in Kansas City
against the Hunters.
And it's just the show not waiting long
to pay off the scene of her finding a gun
after asking Joe and test for one
so many times
like, Oh, I found a gun,
this will come in handy.
And then boom, next episode
it comes in real handy.
A lot of her arc,
especially early in the game
here, is experiencing things
for the first time as she literally says
both cool stuff and experiencing
traumatic stuff for the first time.
One of them is actually having to kill
a regular person for the first time.
She's killed, infected
before she met Joel.
She was traumatized by that,
and we'll see that in future flashbacks.
But up to this point, she's never actually
had to kill a regular person
that was not infected
like these Hunter characters.
And it's just another step on her
path to toughening up
and learning to survive on her own.
She's not completely helpless.
But as you see in the trailer
so far, in all the episodes,
she can barely read a map,
so she has a long way to go before
she could survive completely on her own
long term.
If you spotted any other Easter eggs
or references in the trailer
that I didn't mention in the video.
Right them below in the comments
made for Last of US Episode four video
we'll post Sunday after they release it.
There was a brand New Mandalorian Season
three trailer.
I'm working on a new video for that.
It is a real big thing
that's happening right after I'm posting
this video is James
Gunn is meant to announce his new DC Phase
one slate of movies
in the new Superman movie.
Like all the big rebooted DC movies,
of course I'll do videos for all the stuff
that he announces.
Make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel
so you don't miss any of those.
Congratulations, Space Invader.
You're the giveaway winner for my last
last of US episode video.
Please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
Everyone click here for my For Last of US
Episode three Video
and Easter Eggs and click here
for All my last demos episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.